from the mornings you ease to the
evenings you quiet to the
dreams you inhabit
my thoughts of you never end reggae jean
page will not be returning as the duke
of hastings for season two
of bridgerton but in so removing it we
found something
far greater the british actor's exit was
announced on friday via twitter through
a message from the town's gossip maven
lady whistle down reading quote while
all eyes turned to lord anthony
bridgerton's quest to find a viscountess
we bit a dude to regain jean page who so
triumphantly played the duke of hastings
we'll miss simon's presence on screen
but he will always be a part of the
bridgerton family
i just managed to make such a terribly
unbecoming sound while laughing
paige took to twitter after the
announcement expressing his gratitude
writing quote pleasure and a privilege
and honored to be a member of the family
on and off screen cast crew and
incredible fans
the love is real and will just keep
growing the breakout star's exit from
the series comes as a shocker
as his character simon remains a
presence throughout the rest of author
julia quinn's best-selling novel series
upon which the bridgerton tv show is
based bridgerton's tv series creator
shonda rhimes shared a message on
instagram saying goodbye to the duke of
hastings but also
shared this reminder remember the duke
is never gone
he's just waiting to be binge watched
all over again
seeing what uh an emotional connection
people have formed with the work that we
put out which is everything you ever
want
as an artist is everything you kind of
dream of achieving and hope to achieve
every time it's wonderful to see it come
to life
ever since bridgerton dropped on
christmas paige's star has risen
exponentially tell me your name
your name sir am i honestly to believe
you do not already know my name
the actor made his saturday night live
hosting debut in february
and he's booked high-profile gigs
including ryan gosling and chris evans
upcoming film
the gray man he's also slated to star in
the film adaptation
of dungeons and dragons and get this
he's already racking up trophies
paige nabbed an naacp image award for
outstanding actor in a drama series
and he's up for two screen actors guild
awards this weekend
including one for his individual
performance i think that one of the most
important things about the idea of the
happy ending is that it doesn't
end there like love is a continuous
process it needs
tending it needs work it needs it gets
tested
and i think that you'll if we carry that
story forward it would about
be about showing the true strength of
this is in how it continues to
work and grow and evolve it's a living
thing that you've got to feed and
move and grow with as for paige's
romantic interest on screen
actress phoebe denver she's returning as
daphne bridgerton
the friday announcement also shared that
daphne will remain a devoted wife and
sister
all while helping her brother navigate
social season plus
more intrigue and romance than my
readers may be able to bear
if the only outstanding gentleman
present this evening are your brothers
then we're in a great deal of trouble
indeed
you continue to see weak season two
which begins production this spring in
london follows anthony bridgerton
as he sets out to dominate social season
anthony himself jonathan bailey recently
spoke with et to offer a preview of
what's to come
it's just going to get more exciting
convoluted and sexier
i think um chris van dusen the
showrunner has got this amazing ability
to take julia quinn's
extraordinary books and her amazing
worlds and she's so delicately and
you know filled full of sort of
excitement and sexiness and
he takes it to a whole other level so
the fact that we're following
anthony's pursuit for love shows that
there's going to be definitely some
[Music]
similarities
you